2部始まります はい あの少々また別にアーナンダ尊者の経歴というか
経歴でも冗談で書いたんですけど
阿ミト王の息子 釈尊の父をスッドーデラの弟です
ということは親戚ですね
バッディーアヌルッダバグキンビラデーヴァダッタという釈族の王子たちと
ウパーリという家来と一緒に釈尊が悟り開いて二年目で出家したんです
で この名前に出てくる方々はみんな大物で
バグキンビラ二人がなんかちょっと思い出しませんだけどね
アンルッダ長老とウパーリ長老が
この戒律の専門家になったのは
このウパーリという長老なんですね
えーと そこであのお釈迦様はやっぱりあのそばに体のね
壊れかけてる体の不自由だらしないところはね
やっぱり親族の人々にね
面倒見て欲しかったんですね
やっぱりこの釈族としてのプライド
王家のプライドも そこはやっぱり家柄に対して不名誉なことをしないっていうことも
まあたとえブッダであってもあったんですよ
だからまあ社会から見れば
何かなることはしなかったんですね
そういうわけで まあ個人的にお釈迦様がまあどんな風に至っても
まあ義理の兄弟だからね
義理の兄弟なんて言いますか
おじさんの息子だからいとこですね
まあいとこですからね
まあどうったことはないんですね
まあ逆にリラックスできるし
お互いのね 個人的な生き方は全部まあ知り尽くしているし
同じ環境でね 育てられたし
そういうことで やっぱり従者としてはね
まあ普通に考えても まあいい存在でしたでしょうと思います
この中で問題になったのはだいぶだけなんですね
釈尊から直に出家をいただくが
師匠はベッラってシーサ阿羅漢でした
お釈迦様はいきなりこのグループにはね
一言葉でじゃあ出家認めますということで
比丘は全部兵糧です 沙弥会も比丘会もまあ一発で認めますと一言葉で
そんなこと言われたっても
また弟子入りしなくちゃいけないんだからね
もう誰かを師匠同志として認定して
その同志のそばで学ばなくちゃいけないんですね
このベッラってシーサという阿羅漢のところでいろいろ細かいことを学んだそうですね
ブンナマンターニプッタ阿羅漢の説法を聞いて
ソーターパンナ預流果の悟りに達するんですね
かなり早いうちに このブンナマンターニプッタ
このという有名な長老なんですね
この南のほうのお坊様なんですね
お釈迦様弟子たちの中で
それほど南の方から人々は少なかったんです
かなり遠いところから
南から北に行って出家した方で
阿羅漢になってから本人が自分が田舎に帰りそうと
そちら辺で仏教は誰もお釈迦様もいらっしゃらないし
自分が広げるそうと言ったら
このお釈迦様がこの伝道する人が学ぶべきことを
マンターニプッタ長老に教えるんですよ
で 誰も仏教のことを知らない境地で
で お釈迦様の方は環境は良かったし
お釈迦様はすっごい有名でしたし
で 敵わないし 誰お釈迦様にはね
コウサラ国の一部になっちゃったんです
お釈迦様の国が しかし
コウサラ国そのものがインドで一番大きい巨大な国でしたし
コウサラ王様とはまあ出家する前からもう知り合いで
次の大きい国はマガダ国でしたし
そのマガダ王様は友人で
出家する以前からもう
だからそこら辺で活動するっていうこと
お釈迦様にとってはもう何のこともないんです
お釈迦様に対して反対とかね
逆らうとかね これは成り立ちません
しかし じゃあ仏教は世界人類のために語られたもので
お釈迦様は最初の 60人の阿羅漢たちにも
これから人類の幸福を目指して一人一人を説法しなさいと
仏教が史上最初の国際宗教なんです
伝道は仏教が始めたんです
他の宗教はないんです
伝道といえば 国際スケールでやらなくちゃいけないんだから
人類に真理を語らなくちゃいけないんです
他の宗教はすべて民族宗教なんですよ
みんな今勘違いしていて
キリスト教も民族宗教で
ユダヤ教は民族宗教で
イスラム教は民族宗教で
ヒンドゥー教は明らかにインド人の宗教で国際性はないんです
人類に普遍ということはほとんど全くない
あれは強引にそのところだけ取り上げて言っているだけで
それでもイスラム教に改宗したら
アラビア文化の人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
だからそれってちょっと仏教は良くないと思いますね
人類学的に人間には文化というものがありますね
文化というのは我々の生き方ですから
これは何千年もずっと生き方していますからね
例えば皆様 仏教徒になってからは箸を使うことをやめなさいと言われるとすごく困るでしょ
仏教徒なら徒なら箸で食べてはいけませんよと文化壊しちゃうと困りますよ
で インドではお釈迦様が手で召し上がりましたから
皆様も手で食べてくださいと
こんなのおかしい だからこの文化を守って伝道しなくちゃいけない
我々にとってはそう簡単に文化を変えることはできません
なんで何言われたっても
それは生き方なんですね
だから仏教はそういうわけで国際宗教なんです
文化を守り 守りつつ真理を語るという
ですから このマンターニブッタ長老がダッキーナアギリという南の方に行きたいと言ったら
お釈迦様がこれまた冗談で
ユーモアで軽々く語るんですよ
しかし 中の意味は大変です
お釈迦様いうのは こんなこの南の人々は結構乱暴だよ
本人も南なんですけど
結構乱暴だよ あなたに悪口言うかもしれませんよ
批判するかもしれませんよと言ったら
こんな長老が でもお釈迦様
私は北南の人々はね 親切だと思いますよと
なぜかというと 悪口ぐらい言っただけでね
殴ったりしないんだからね
親切だと思います ただ
お釈迦様がそう言ってもね
南の人々はもうもう乱暴だからね
殴れる 殴られる可能性ありますよと言ったら
長老が でもお釈迦様 私は私の田舎の人々は親切だと思いますよと
まあ殴られたってまあ怪我させるっていうことはないんだからねと
ただお釈迦様は ではではではなくて
そんなこと言ってもね
殴って怪我させる可能性はありますよと
あなたには説法したら
怖いんですよ そういう人々はと
そしたら いい お釈迦様
その人は親切だよと 殴って怪我させちゃっても殺しはしませんだからね
私は親切だと思いますよと
そしたらお釈迦様が そんなこと言っていてもね
殴って怪我させて殺す可能性もありますよと
あなた殺される可能性もありますよ
そちらで伝道始めたら
そしたらこんな長老がまあ
それでも私は親切だと思いますよと
なぜかというと 私にとってはやるべきことはやり終わっているし
なすべきことはなし終えているし
体を持つこと自体は単なる食うだけでね
早く亡くなった方が涅槃に入られますよと
だから私はずっと寿命を全うして死ぬまで待つことをね
すごい早めに早めにしてくれるんだから
早く涅槃に入れてくれるんだからね
それはとても親切だと思いますよと
あ だったら行きなさいよと
それでお釈迦様はOK出すんですね
だからその中に この伝道に行く人々の心構え
最も簡単なエピソードでわかりやすく語っていますよ
覚えておけば もうどんな出家でもしっかりした伝道師にはなります
だから この何言われたっても気にしないと
だから私にも何言われても目がないんです
めげないんです 気にもしない
尊敬した戦友たち やはり先輩ですね
阿難尊者は一応年下とそういうところで書かれてますけどね
まあ先輩たちがいたんですね
尊敬する それはマハーモッガッラーサリプッタ
マハーモッガラーナ マハーカッサパ
アヌーッダ カンカーレーワタ
という偉大なる方々なんですね
アナンド尊者が尊敬する
それで このサーリプッタ尊者がアナンダ尊者のことを大変評価するんです
なぜかというと もうサーリプッタ尊者が授舎になりたかったんです
でも断られたんです だから
自分がやりたかった仕事ができる人は羨ましいというね
羨ましいといえば俗世間の言葉だから
私はそれは避けたんです
すごいことであると 自分にも資格がない
なのにアナンド尊者にすごい資格があるということで
サーリプッタ尊者はかなりアナンド尊者のことはまあ評価するんです
で アナンド尊者もそうですよ
サーリプッタ尊者のことをすっごく尊敬する
智慧の第一人者ということで
こちらも知識人でしょうし
学者でしょうに だから結構お互い合うものはいっぱいあるんですね
そこでいろんなところでサーリプッタ尊者のことはものすごく褒め称えた経典もあります
アナンダ尊者が一生懸命褒め称えて
サーリプッタ尊者に会ってよかったと
である日ね お釈迦様 アナンダ尊者がすごい高価な布生地を一ついただくんですよ
で 自分がすぐ使わなきゃ
これは個人財産で禁止なんです
仏教では で 使えないならばサンガに誰かにあげなくちゃいけないんです
だから自分のものとして 10 日間ぐらいですね
持てるのは 10 日間過ぎるとと
私の個人的に受けたものですが
これはサンガのものにしますと
で 放棄しなくちゃいけないんです
しかし アナンド尊者がこのすごい大事な生地をもらって
すごいいいもので これをサーリプッタ尊者にあげたいんですね
これ 10日以内でやらないと
自分のものである限り
ある間では渡せます 10
日過ぎたらサンガのものだから
サンガはくじで次の人を決めるんです
そうすると権利がなくなるんです
でお釈迦様に言って 自分の考え方を言って特別許可もらうんです
置いておいてもよろしいという
日にち過ぎても それぐらいサーリプッタ尊者のことをすごい尊敬していたんです
マハーカッサパ尊者は特別にアーナンダ尊者に目をつけていたんです
これでマハーカッサパ大尊者がいて
どうしてもアーナンダ尊者を狙っているんです
しかし マハーカッサパ尊者はあんまり比丘サンガの前には来ないんです
ずっと森の中で洞窟があって
この洞窟の中に生活するんです
一般の人々にはあまり会わないんです
托鉢に出る場合は 一番社会で最低のホームレスやら乞食やら不可触民族やら
そういう人々がいるところに行って托鉢をしていただき
ご飯をいただいてさっと戻る
その人々に説法したりはする
この偉い人々のところには行かなかったんです
なのに アーナンダ尊者にはもう狙っているんです
もう偉大なる方々だからね
もう能力は知っているしね
どういう風？これが結構お互い喧嘩する羽目になったんですよ
批判された 叱られたことも経典に記録してあります
カッサパ尊者がアーナンダ尊者を褒めることはだいたいないんです
何か言うんです あれがダメ
これがダメとか よくだらしないと言われるんですね
あの偉大なるアーナンダ尊者のこと
しかし アーナンダ尊者を尊敬している方だから
アーナンダ尊者はそれには何も言いません
でも何か言われると知ってます
会ったら何か言われて
何言われたってアーナンダ尊者はもうすごい忙しいんだから
一番仏教の中で忙しかったのはアーナンダ尊者ですから
まだ青いと言われて まあ本当の言葉は愚か者よとお前はと
愚か者の単語には意味 2つあります
年下と経験不足という頭悪い意味だけではないんです
年下という意味でも 仏教ではバーラという言葉を使うんです
で まあ日本風に言えば青いというぐらいかな
言われて アーナンダ尊者が自分の頭は白毛いっぱいなのにと言い返しちゃったんです
微妙に我慢できなかったでしょうね
あんたね まだまだ経験不足で青いんだと
長老がそう言われても
私はもう髪の毛はほとんど白いんだよと
そしたら髪の毛が白くなったってものもやっていることはね
何やと また帰る 返すんです
特に批判したのはあなた尊者の性格ではないんです
あなた尊者のこの人間関係なんです
いろんな人と人間関係を持たなくちゃいけないでしょ
仕事上 これが気に入らなかったんです
カッサパ尊者が誰ともコミュニケーションしないで一人でいる人だからね
だから性格正反対なんです
正反対なのに アーナンダ尊者のことは評価して
この人は何とかして何とかしなくちゃという
気持ちがあるんですね
はい そのエピソードは後で時間があったら紹介します
アナンダ尊者の仕事内容
これ全部じゃない ほんの僅か僅かしか紹介できません
常にブッダのそばにいる
いつでもそばにいるんです
一回呼ばれたら行けるように気を付けているんです
侍者に認定したその瞬間から
お釈迦様 アーナンダと一回呼んだら
はい お釈迦様という風に言えるように距離でいるんです
本人決めたそうです 二回呼ばれるないようにしますよと
水を汲み お湯やら歯磨きなどなど
そういう日常生活に必要なものはアナンダ尊者がいつでも用意するんです
お釈迦様が朝外へ出ると
ちゃんとお湯とか用意してあるんです
歯磨くものとかね お釈迦様お説教したりするときでも
そばにいて一生懸命面倒を見るんですね
それから当然のこと お釈迦様の部屋の掃除やらね
全部アナンダ尊者の仕事
ほか誰もやりません 足を洗ってあげたりする
お釈迦様の部屋に入る入ろうとすると
アナンダ尊者がさっさと玄関で足を洗う水を用意して足を洗ってあげたりする
旅に一緒に出る お釈迦様出かけるならば
アナンダ尊者は必ず一緒に出るんです
夜 松明を持って九回釈尊が住んでいる部屋を巡回するんです
夜寝ていないんですよ
24年間 お釈迦様の部屋にも入れませんし
守るを九回巡回するんです
釈尊が比丘たちに話したくなる時
何かの用事で比丘たちを呼びたくなる時
それをアナンダ尊者が比丘たちに報告するんです
だからアナウンサーはアナンダ尊者なんです
遠いところの比丘でも呼びたくなったら
アナンダ尊者行かなくちゃいけないんですよ
行ってあなたを呼んでいるんだよと
比丘たちの報告はすべてアナンダ尊者がするんです
周りに起こる様々な出来事を釈尊に報告する
で いろんな出来事が起きたら
仏教に関心ある 興味ある
いろいろ全部お釈迦様には報告するんです
例えば ジャイナ教の教祖様
ニガンタさんが亡くなられた時は
お釈迦様にお釈迦様ニガンタさんが亡くなられたんだと
亡くなられてすぐみんなすごい喧嘩になっているんだと
弟子たちが という報告やらね
誰が有名な在家の信者さんでも亡くなったら
あの人が亡くなられたとかね
報告はずっとお釈迦様に情報提供するんです
人々に比丘たちにアドバイスが必要だとわかったら
ブッダに報告する で アナンダ尊者が考えたら
お釈迦様がご自分であの人のところに行って説法した方がいいんじゃないかなとか
本人感じたらお釈迦様に言うんです
お釈迦様 あの人を喋った方がいいんじゃないんでしょうか？とかね
例えば 邪教の他の宗教の人々でもいろいろお騒ぎしたりすると
あなたその場合 お釈迦様いたら何か言った方がいいんじゃないかと自分が判断したら
お釈迦様に報告するんです
大体お釈迦様を従うんです
女性の出家もアナンダ尊者の協力で成り立ったんです
アナンダ尊者がいなかったら
女性の出家はないんです
第一結集で経典法というのは法ですね
すべて教えたのはアナンダ尊者でしたが
それは従者としての役割というより
尊者の桁違い 才能 知識によるものだとした方が良いと思います
従者だからやったんではなくて
ご自分がすごい才能 天才的な才能を持っていたんだから
そのおかげで第一結集で全てのブッダの言葉を残るようになりました
カッサパ尊者が狙ったのはそこなんです
この人だけ仏教に対して財産だよと
もう生きている宝物なんです
もうお釈迦様のお世話でもうもうすごい普通の
ごく普通のことで忙しくているのはね
これは断れないし なんかもったいないという気持ちもあったでしょうね
毎日もう薪を焚いてお釈迦様のお湯を作っているわ
あ この方 こんなことやっていいのかと
という気持ちもあったでしょうし
だからアナンタさんには弟子を作ることもできたんですけど
もう弟子の面倒を見ていられません
ものすごい忙しいんでしたから
そういうことだから いつでもカッサパ尊者がなんとか一言葉言って決着つけちゃうんです
だからそれは嫌味ではなかったんですよ
ものすごい長老として
先輩としての言葉でしたからね
だからお釈迦様は涅槃に入られて
3ヶ月間で第三決 第一決集を決めることを決めて
アナンタカッサパ尊者決めるんです
大体仏教は予言ない世界ですけど
先を知っているんです
お釈迦様が涅槃に入る前に
サーリプッタ尊者とモクレン尊者が涅槃に入られたんです
次に3番目に行ったのはカッサパ尊者が第一になったんです
第一になってもお釈迦様のところに行かないんです
偉大なる弟子たちは次から次へと涅槃に入られちゃうんですよ
お釈迦様と同じ年か年上かでしたからね
それであるお釈迦様がね
今寂しいんだと 比丘たちは大物たちはほとんどほとんどないんだと
サーリプッタない モクレン尊者がない
比丘たちはなんか虚しく感じますよと
言ってもカッサパ尊者はそばに行かないんです
涅槃に入ってから あ 責任重大だと言って盛りを下りたんです
その時降りたんです 降りて戻らないんです
全責任ブッダの代わりに担ったんです
担って 今現在まで仏教は残るようにやるべきことは全部やって終わったんです
ああいう方々っていうのはもう人間じゃないんですよ
本当 まあ真面目な人間じゃない
阿羅漢ですからね だったら一人が行うことでどれほど結果が出るのかと
カッサパ尊者が第一決集を行ったんだからこそ
仏教が残ったんです 修行法残ったんです
弟子を作る伝統が残ったんです
で それにはアナンダ尊者がないとできないんです
それで最後の最後もカッサパ尊者のいじめ
で 500人選びますよと言って
いろいろお坊さん 阿羅漢たちに頼んで
そのその才能 才能あるお坊さんたちだけを集めてくださいと言って 499
人決めるんです で じゃあここでやりますと
499人で アナンダ尊者は入れない
この人がいないとどうやってやるんですかね
ったらその問題になるでしょ
なんでアナンダ尊者カットしたんですか？と
だってあの人まだ悟ってないんだからね
ちょっとでも主観が入ったら困りますよと
第一には悟ってますけど
完全阿羅漢じゃないんだからね
微妙にでも自分の意見を言ったりするとどうするんですかと
でも困ったもんですね
あの人はないと決集は成り立たないし
しかし入ったら困るし
といってさっさとね 一応一つ残してますからね
アスタダヨとかさ と叱って帰ったんです
だからお互いよく知ったことで
やっぱりアナンダ尊者の席があるんですけど
やっぱりカッサパ尊者が長老だからね
このしつけはずっと甘くは見ないんです
アナンダ尊者もすごい立派な方だから
やっぱりカッサパ尊者の気持ちをわかって
その夜瞑想を始めるんです
明日の朝だからね で 朝に悟る
朝は悟りに達しますよ
で 達して御坊さんたちが進めているところで
さっと自分の超能力でさっと行って現れたんです
しかし あ 来たのかというような感じで来たの
じゃあ座りなさいとかいうぐらいの話ですよ
だから悟ったと 梵天がカッサパ尊者に報告をしたんです
悟りました 大丈夫や そういうことだから
初めからもう計画的に狙っていたんです
マハーカッサパ尊者がアナンダ尊者に期待した仕事です
だからマハースカ尊者かアナンダ尊者
従者としてはお釈迦様がいるだけですからね
それよりあなたには仏教に責任があるんだよと
これはもっと大事だよという態度なんです
しかし 一晩で修行を完成して最終解脱に達しなさいと条件もつけたんです
それからもう一つ アナンダ尊者の性格
命を惜しまないという
釈尊のことをあまりにも心配していたんです
いつでも釈尊のために自分の命を捨てる気持ちでいたんです
命でも捨てると言う なんかボディガード役までやっているという
巡回もするんだから 何かあったらもう自分の命を差し上げますよと
ケースがあったんです
だいぶデーヴァダッタがこのナーラギリという象に酒を飲ませてね
酔わせて狂暴にさせてね
怒らせて お釈迦様が来る道に追い出したんです
で 頭がイカれちゃって
もう戦争に訓練させてるそうでしょうし
みるみるものを壊すんです
で 結構家を壊しながらお釈迦様の前に出るんですよ
来るとアナンダ尊者が自分で前に出るんです
お釈迦様 お釈迦様は出て行ってくださいと
道を外してくださいと
私は前に出ますと だからアナンダ尊者を潰す間でお釈迦様には逃げられます
お釈迦様がね そんなことをやるなよと
やる必要ないんだと って言っても
もう前に出て お釈迦様を置いといて
本人が前に行くんです ３
回もお釈迦様がもうやめなさいと
そんなことは 聞かない
お釈迦様に逆らってまでお釈迦様に対してもう命をあげたいという
それで何をしたかというとお釈迦様は自分の神通力で自分をぎゅっと変えたんです
でお釈迦様の力はもう理解しない方がいいんです
自分が変えたら自分がお尻られるんです
結構 でお釈迦様はなんのことなく
ナーラギリさんにね 名前も知ってるし
お釈迦様は葬祭には慣れたもんだからね
なんのことなく 君 なんでこんなに興奮しているんですか？と
落ち着きなさいよと一言で葬さんが落ち着いたんです
落ち着いて膝を曲げてね
もう座ったんです で 私も一回やったことがあるんです
別に私を殺しに来たわけじゃなくて
鎖でつなげていたんですけど
頭がおかしくなりますからね
雄は 喋ったらすぐ気持ちが変わるんですよ
しかし この喋り方 この葬祭は怖くて命令するだけでね
私はそんな名前聞いて名前も名前知らないと名前周りから聞いてもらって
名前で呼んで 普通の若い男の子を呼ぶような感じで
君大変ですね どうかね
ったら真っ赤な目がきっと青くなっちゃったんです
持って私の方見て 私もそこでベラベラベラベラいろいろ喋ってるんです
すっごい落ち着くんですよ
あの時は やっぱりまあ慈しみで優しく喋れば
まあそうというのは人間より頭が大きいんだからね
いい悪いはわかりませんだけど
大きいことだけは確かですから
よくわかりますよ あの動物は人間の言葉はわからないんだけど
これは人間の失敗なんですよ
言語を使うということは
我々は言語でコミュニケーションしているわけじゃないんです
言語の裏にある気持ちでコミュニケーションしているんです
だから私のことを結構馬鹿にされますけどね
もう偉そうなことどうしゃべってるんだと
でも私は何かを言ってます
それはわかってますよ
猫が寝ていると 今このリーマンブラザーズの倒産している
あんたよく寝ているもんだなとかね
言うんですよ 気にしないの？とかね
別にそんな猫に関係ないんで
みんな私は頭がおかしいと思うでしょうね
でもないんで 私はコミュニケーション取っているんです
そこで何が猫が理解するかで
それぞれ世界は別々だよと
で これ聞いて猫何やるのかと
じゃあ俺が寝るぞともっと気持ちよく寝るんです
それちゃんと伝わっているんです
それぞれの世界が別やと
その時 アマナスは三回も釈尊に言われたのに従わなかったのです
それから偉大なる知識人がアナンダ尊者
偉大な知識人であることはあんまり情報出してないんです
この場合は今日はちょっとありすぎ
アナンダ尊者に説かれた経典があります
アナンダ尊者が説かれた経典はあります
結構あります で ちょっとだけはアンゴッドリニカーティカニパータのアナンドワッガっていう一つ多いんですけど
アナンドワッガっていう経典ありまして
その中で三つぐらいアナンダ尊者直々
他はお釈迦様との対話
それから釈尊が病気が治った間もないうちに
釈尊のマハーナーマが質問するんです
お釈迦様はある日病気でになっていたんです
アナンダ尊者が看病して
やっと病気が治りました
治ったのでもマハーナーマ釈尊の人が堂々と来るんですね
釈尊の人々はだいたい十年で会うんですよ
で アナンダ尊者 アナンダ尊者にやめなさいということもちょっと言いづらいし
同じ親戚でしょうね 親戚同士ですからね
で 結構難しい質問するんですよ
アナンダ尊者がすごい
これはもう大変ですと
お釈迦様にはと言って
質問に何かすごい割り込んで
自分が説法するんです
ずっと答えていくんで
これはこれこれこれと喜んで帰るんです
お釈迦様に説法させない
その場合はどうしても説法しなければいけないんだけど
自分がやる ちゃんと質問に答えて
だからすごい知識ですよ
また 中部経典のサンダカスッタっていうのはアナンダ尊者のスッタで
バッデグラとスッタは三つありますけど
一つはアナンダ尊者やって
まだたくさんの経典が見つけたんですけど
忘れた 注釈書を見るともう大量にデータがあるんですね
女性の解放にすごい力を入れたんです
比丘尼出家はアナンダ尊者の計らいです
お釈迦様をなんとなく微妙に騙しちゃったんですよ
で すごい女性解放にはすごい
持っていたんです もうなんか認めなかったんですね
女性差別は インドにも激しかったんだからね
すごい激しかったんです
女性には何の立場もない
ただ子供を産んで料理を作ればいい
それ以上あれと それでお釈迦様の人見ても
世間の文化に習慣には逆らったらまずいんですね
で 女性は出家しない方がいいやという立場でお釈迦様もいるんです
出家して出家になりたくなったのはまずいことにお釈迦様の母親なんですね
なおさらダメというんですね
いくらなんでも母親に苦労させたくないんだからね
まあ宮殿でいてくださいと
何が文句あるんですか？という断る
でも頑固ですからね まあそれで勝手に出家してね
裸足で歩いてきて でお釈迦様は許可しないし
にも認めないし 行くところもないし
あまりにも惨めな姿になっちゃって
なんでそんなにと言ってみれば
自分の親戚でもあるでしょう
自分にしたっておばあちゃんだからね
おばさんだから で お釈迦様には言っても断る
言っても断る 回以上は言えませんだからね
ブッダには断る 何回も言ったら
アナンダ尊者には契約書ではどんな思想もできますからね
契約だから でお釈迦様ということは
女性が出家したら 出家して修行したら悟れないですかねと
そんなことないんだよと
修行したら誰でも悟りに達しますよと
人間なら誰でも悟れるんだっていうのは
法律も法則だからね うーん
まあそういうことですね
ということは 女性に出家禁止ということは
解脱は禁止ということになるんですねと
お釈迦様はもうすぐまんまとはまったんですね
この仕掛けに 出家して修行すれば
早くも簡単に最終解脱に達する
再婚では悟りますけど
最終の段階には達しませんだからね
ということは 女性に出家禁止ということは
最終解脱は禁止ということになりますと
お釈迦様がやっぱりやられたなと思ったでしょうね
でも儒者だからね 怒りはきないけませんし
じゃあ特別条件をつけますよと
ちょっと嫌になる条件
女性が 項目を付けたんです
それに OK するならば
まあ認めますと 言ったら
まあ女性が嫌になる条件といえば
この いくら出家しても尼さんは年取っても
比丘に礼をしなくちゃいけない
比丘 男性の比丘に 例えばある比丘尼が出家して年だとしましょう
年上ですよ ある男が出家して
まあ 1 週間ですね しかし
こちらに頭を下げて礼をしなくちゃいけないんだと
これ 結構腹が立つことでしょうね
それは認めなくちゃいけないんだ
これでお釈迦様が言うのは
やっぱりまずいんだと
インドの社会においてはね
男が女性に土下座させて頭を下げるってやるということは
世間は認めませんよと
そこで問題ないように
まあいくらなんでもそういう条件をつけておいたんだ
それからね 比丘がいないところで住むなかれとかね
一緒に生活は禁止ですけど
やっぱり守ってあげたいんですよ
男性がいないところで女性一人ばっかりいるとね
大変危険だからね 月に一回
比丘たち比丘誰か一人を自分の尼寺に呼ばなく呼んで
戒律項目を唱ってもらわなくちゃいけないとか
いくつかですよ それでパジャーティゴートゴータミーさんがありがたく受けますと
と言ったんです その一言で出家成立
契約だからね これ認めるならば
おそらくお釈迦様があのががすごい態度高いゴータミーさんが母親ですからね
認め認めないだろうと期待した可能性もあります
すごい家族のね シャカ族の人がカーストは何ともわからない男にも頭下げなくちゃいけないんだからね
これはシャカ族としては無理なんです
認めないだろうと思ったんですけど
何のことなく認めますと言われたんだから
しまったなと お釈迦様の反応は
でお釈迦様は負けたんですね
とにかく やっぱりそこまでアーナンダ尊者か女性のために頑張ったんです
比丘尼たちにたくさん説法なさったんです
それだけじゃなくて アーナンダ尊者がもうすっちょびくたちに比丘尼たちがいるところに行って説法するんです
責任持ったんです アーナンダ尊者に説法してもらうならば
もうこの上ないんだから
もうもうもう全部覚えてるんだから
アーナンダ尊者がもう比丘尼たちに説法する機会がなかったとかなんかは
すぐわかったらすぐそこ行って教えてあげたりする
コーサラ王の妃たちに続けて説法なさったこともあります
毎日説法を聞きたいと言われちゃってね
お妃たちが はぁ やっぱりみんな嫌がりますね
お坊さんたちは宮殿に行かなくちゃいけないんだから
宮殿というのは男はもう入らないところなんです
それでしょうがなく アーナンダ尊者になっちゃったんです
アーナンダ尊者は行っても説法したんですよ
それでお妃たちに この王様が新しい服をね
みんなに一人人ぐらいいたみたいですね
ハールですからね みんなに着
着与えたんです そしたら
この方々はまあ全部アーナンダ尊者に寄付しちゃった
お布施しちゃったんです
王様が見たら 誰も新しい服を着ていないんです
どうなったんですかと
あなた方のと思う したら
我々はそれお布施しましたと
誰に？アーナンダ尊者に
王様に考えられないで
着ですよ これアーナンダ尊者が持っていったんです
とにかく ただ これはとんでもないことやと
言って訴えに行ったんです
それはアンさんです もらいましたよと
それでそれ持ってきたの
持ってきましたよ それでどうするんで
あれは配りました じゃあそれだけあれはみんなに配りました
自分で一つも使っていないんです
王様に何とも言うことなく
はい わかりましたということで帰ってきたんです
なぜ女性は社会で認められてないのか
なぜ議会などに参加しないのかなどの質問も釈尊にしたのです
よくそういうことはアーナンダ尊者にとってはもうもうなかなか認められないんですね
例えばワッジ国は議会制度で
全部男だけ議員なんですね
なんで女性はないんですか？とかね
なんで社会のいろんな活動
行事があるときは 女性が後ろに下がっていなくちゃあかんですか？とかね
なんで女性の発言は認めないんですか？とか
そういう質問するんですよ
だから結構女性解放運動に
女性差別問題に力を入れた方なんです
で これでトラブルとトラブルがなかったわけじゃないんです
で アーナンダ尊者がもうカッサパ尊者
目連尊者はサーリプッタ尊者とは仲良く友達みたいにガヤガヤ喋ったりするんだけど
カッサパ尊者は手強いんだからね
厳しいんだから 自分を叱ったりするんだから
だから女性たちもしっかりしてほしいという気持ちがあるんですよ
しっかりしなさいよと
後ろに下がるんじゃないよという気持ちがあるんです
しかし 自分だけ説法するでしょうに
そこである日 カッサパ尊者が来たら
カッサパ尊者にそういう分丁寧に挨拶を礼をして
尼寺で説法をなさっていただけませんか？と
で それで行ったんです
で カッサパ尊者がすごいお年上
年上です 出家しても年上です
で 阿羅漢でしょうし その信者がうーんという感じで
まあと言って説法したんです
アナンド尊者もいる ある尼さんがね
悪口言ったんです よくもアーナンダ尊者がいるところで説法するもんでですね
何者だと思ってるんですかと
なんかあの針職人に針を売ってる商人
商売人 商人みたいな 針だから針をわざと作ったから
針を作るために昔はかなり技術必要でしたからね
だから今技術社会だから我々にとってはもうあまり感動しませんだけど
針を作る 針を作る職人にある人が針を売ろうとしているんです
話にならないですね これが
すごい侮辱なんです ただ
カッサパ尊者 そんなものは認めるわけじゃないけど
もの厳しい方だから それでアナンド尊者の顔を見て
アーナンダ で 針職人 私が針職人ですかね
あんた針を 私が針の職人
あんた針を針を作る職人ですかね
と言ったんです だってカッサパ尊者はもう目連第3番目ですからね
大阿羅漢でしょうし 神通力もあってものすごい方なんですよ
その人にこの女がこんなことを言うと
しかし その時もアーナンダ尊者の性格はすごく見えるんです
アナンド尊者はその女性を叱らなかったんです
カッサパ尊者に この愚か者
女っていうのは頭が悪んだからね
頭が悪くてもうどうにもならんですからね
という反応なんです やっぱり私はその反応でね
申し訳ない 申し訳ない
なんでそんなことを言うんだよ
謝りなさいとか そこもなく
女ってもうどうにもならん
頭が悪くてと アナンド尊者も飽きていたでしょうね
あれほど頑張ったのにね
もうもううまくいかなかったんだから
結局は女性たちはいろいろトラブルを作るわ
感情を引き起こすわ 結構大変でしたからね
せっかくアナンド尊者が平等対等にしてあげようと思っているのに
こちら上がってこないんですね
だからもうあげたもんやと
アナンド尊者に言われたら
カッサパ尊者は何も言わないで帰ったんです
それからアナンド尊者がかなり病人の心配する
これにもすごい興味を持っていたんですね
アナータピンディコジが病気になると
アーナンダ尊者を呼ぶんです
アナータピンディコジっていうのは
サイケの第一ですよ サイケ男性の第一
ウィサーカーが女性の第一
自分が病気でもうどうにもない
もう機嫌が悪くなってくると
さっさとアーナンダ尊者を呼んでくださいと言うんです
アナンド尊者は来て もう看病
面倒を見て 何か説法してあげて
なんとか してあげるんです
シリワッデ マーナディンナとか
この経典に記録されているところなんですね
結構人が病気になると
やっぱりアナンド尊者にはいたいという気分になるんです
それだけじゃない ある日
看病する人がいなくて死にかけていたティッサという長老が
長老の看病をお釈迦様と一緒に行ったこともあるんです
お釈迦様まで引っ張り出して
その場合はお釈迦様が引っ張り出したわけじゃなくて
お釈迦様はそれを察知している
性格の悪い人が病気になっちゃって
看病したんだけど 若い人々はね
あまりにももう性格悪いんですね
我が強いんですね 若者はもう嫌って辞めちゃうんです
本人がもう身動きできないんですね
だからそのままベッドでもう汚いし
便所に行けないし で 近寄れないぐらい臭くて
体中それでできものができたりして
ひどい臭いでしたそうで
お釈迦様がものすごい臭いがひどいし
まだ知っていて アナンタ尊者一緒にじゃあ二人で看病しましょうと言って
アナンダ尊者がすぐさっさとお湯をたくさん沸かして
お釈迦様と一緒にベッドをベッドのままに外へ出して
二人で体をきれいに洗って
衣も全部脱いで 全部衣も洗って干して
で きれいにしてあげて
それから衣を着させてあげて
全部お釈迦様とアナンダ尊者二人でやるんです
誰も来ないんです で 気分が良くなったところでお釈迦様が説法をするんです
お釈迦様の仕事はそれだから
その方はその日で悟りに達するんです
説法を聞いて で その日で亡くなられたんですけど
で とにかくお釈迦様はお湯をかけたりするし
アナンダ尊者が体をコソコソと洗ったりして
汚いものを全部丁寧に洗ってあげたりするんです
そういうすごい性格なんです
アナンダ尊者は 衣はブッダのアドバイスに合わせてアナンダ尊者がデザインしたんです
これはアナンダ尊者のデザインなんです
で 衣の形がバラバラで
ただ縫い合わせだからね
一貫性がなかったんですね
やっぱりせっかく仏教の比丘たちだからね
衣は一貫性あった方がいいってことになって
どうしようかなと言ったら
お釈迦様はどちらかというと
ご飯食べる文明文化の人だから
田んぼは聖地みたいに思うんですね
ご飯食べる人と麦食べる人の性格違いますよ
ご飯食べる人々っていうのは
ものすごい自然を神様だと思うんですね
日本もそうでしょうし
自然が神様だと思うし
稲でもただの植物じゃないんですよ
やっぱり尊い聖なるものなんです
だから自分の国でも田んぼでは傘させてはいけませんという
誰も傘させません いくら太陽が厳しくたっても
普通は傘させてどこでも行きますけど
田んぼに入ると傘を下げるんです
それはもう稲に対して失礼だと
それぐらい 稲を踏みません
我々は 稲刈りをしたら
模擬を取る場合は足で踏んで取ります
その時仕事ですよ それ以外踏まないんです
もし田んぼで歩けるところありますね
そちらの稲がこうやって落ちていったならば
それを上げてあげるか
踏まないで行くかという
すごい気をつけるんです
そういうことだから あんまりご飯食べる人々は人殺しには行かないという
あまりですね 行ったこともありますからね
自然に生かされているんだからね
お釈迦様の父親もね やっぱり畑をやって田んぼをやっていましたし
それは大きな一つの行事で
お釈迦様が考えたのは
その考え方から じゃあ田んぼの形はどうですか？と言ったら
阿難尊者が考えてデザインしたんです
田んぼの形で衣が ものすごい深い意味ありますよ
だから伝統的にご飯を食べる人々の自然に対する気持ちと
ただもう感謝とかね 生かされているんだと自我が張らない
そういうことで 田んぼの形にして見守っていて
身を守ってもらうものにも田んぼの形はいいんじゃないかって
で デザイナーとしてはいまだにそのデザイン変わってないんだからね
皆様のデザインだったらもう 1ヶ月間も命がないんですね
はい これで終了だと思います
ある地主が法にお布施をしたいとお釈迦様に報告をするんです
ブッダさんが比丘たちにはいっぱい一応いろいろお布施したりしますけど
私は仏法僧だから ブッダと僧にはお布施できますけど
法にもお布施したいんだと
三宝になるようにと 法というのは教えですから
どうやってご飯あげますかね
ただ お釈迦様が釈尊が法にお布施をしたいと思うなら
アーナンダにお布施しなさいと
これジャータカに来るんです
あんた そんなにも法にもお布施したければ
アーナンダがいるでしょうと
アーナンダ長老にお布施したら
それぐらい法と一つにして一心にしてお釈迦様は考えているんです
その場合は仏法であって
真理と一心ではなくて
ブッダの教え言葉と阿難尊者が一心同体なんです
私たちが知っている仏教のすべてが偉大なる儒者阿難尊者の天才能力のおかげです
ですから 入世願文と日本語でいう永万命須単という一言葉
阿難尊者が丁寧に入れてます
その時も謙虚で 私は聞いたごとく言うんですけど
何か異論があったらどうぞという感じなんです
これが仏教やという感じではないんです
私は聞くところによると
私の記憶力が正しければ
お釈迦様はこのように説かれましたよという謙虚さ
それまた学者の方々はまたちょっと信頼できませんと
ブッダの教え これは阿難尊者の言葉やというふうにも言ったりはする場合あるんですけどね
私たちの読みはもっと違います
だから信頼できるんだよと
阿難尊者の意見入ってないんだよと
で いくつかの経典が阿難尊者の入世画面入ってない経典もあります
それはかなり古いんですね
スッタニパータにあるアッタカヴァッガ
パーラヤナヴァッガ ウラダヴァッガとかね
そういうところの経典もありまして
まあそんなところかな
思い出せるところで言えば
で それはまあ大阿羅漢たちも暗記していた経典でね
それ以外はほとんど永万命須単で始まります
はい それで終了です で
阿難尊者がね 智慧の第一人者といって
智慧じゃなくて知識人
学者と言ってもね お釈迦様にはいろいろぶつかったことはありますよという
それが紹介すればそれちゃったんですけど
阿難尊者がある日 お釈迦様にこの因果法則はね
お釈迦様がもう絶対難しいであって
一番難しいのはこれだと言うんだけど
私には軽々理解できるんだよ
と言ったら お釈迦様はなんてこと言うんですか
そんなこと言ってはならんと 3
回もマヘーワーガなと
言うんじゃないんだよと
これでぶつかるんです
お釈迦様と お釈迦様は確かにこれが人間には理解しがたい難しいものであると
因果法則を理解しないんだから
みんな解脱できなくてごちゃごちゃ彷徨っているんだよと
で 因果法則の説法をするんです
お釈迦様が阿難尊者の頼みを断ったこと
ケースもいろいろあるし
いろいろありましたけどね
本当にものすごく美しい人間関係が見えてくるんです
阿難尊者とお釈迦様のこの二人の組合は
で 最後の涅槃経のところはね
阿難尊者もお年の方やと思うと
読めないほど涙が来ないで読めないほどすごい感動的やりとりなんです
お釈迦様も阿難尊者のことをすごく評価して心配するし
阿難尊者も命かけてお釈迦様に命かけて頑張っているし
それでお釈迦様が涅槃に入られてから
阿難尊者が大活躍として
法を置いておいたんです
それから消えるんです
で テーラワーダの伝統ではあまり記録はないんです
ティベットの仏教とか
そういうふうにいろいろ書いてあるみたいですけど
まあちょっと時代 かなり後でのものだからね
信頼性もちょっと問題ですけど
一応話によると アナンタ尊者がそれからこの学学校というか
学派を作ってね 経典を学ぶスートラントというね
まあいわゆる経典を覚えて弟子たちを入れて
自分がみんなに それから次
次の世代に 次の世代にどうやって伝えるのかということで
能力に合わせて分けて分けて分けてあげて
で なさったみたいです
それからずっとその伝統も最近まであったんです
経典を学んで 学んで それから暗記して唱えると
唱えながら 注釈書も一緒に合わせて唱えると
この暗記伝統 すっごく難しいんです
ただ覚えただけでは認めません
で 発音もしっかりしなくちゃいけないし
それからもう日々やらなくちゃいけない
この仏教では この受け上げるというわけもわからない習慣があるでしょ
今なんか神秘になっちゃって
名詞になっちゃって受け上げればいいやと
何の心理もないんですよ
もともとは あれは大事な仕事でした
だって自分の脳細胞が図書館だから
微妙で間違ったら困るんです
だから 1日のスケジュールで
その経典を覚えているお坊さんたちが
必ずしも何時間かと決めて
その時間でずっと経を唱えるんです
それで交代で一人が唱える
もうみんな聞いているという感じにあったり
いろんなもう二人で唱えて
三人で唱えて みんな聞いていて
あるいはみんな一緒に合唱で唱えると
一人の長老がじっとこうやって聞いているとかね
そういうふうに毎日やるんだから
もうもう寝ていても 夢ででもできるぐらい
もうしっかりと記録するんですよ
その方が私たちインド文明の人々にとっては
今は我々壊れましたからね
昔だったらその方がすごい正確で確かなんです
私の子供頃でも 私は厳しく叱られたことがあるんですよ
注釈書の意見までね 暗記してなきゃね
説法師にはならんやと
今こうやって説法していますけど
私の長老だったら お前何やってるのかというでしょうね
まあ本当はこんなものなくても喋れますよ
でもいろいろありますからね
現代時代ではね  こういう風に作りますけど
本当はそういうスライド作らない方が私にとってすごく楽なんです 2
3分考えれば十分です
そこでぴったし時間に秒に合わせて喋ります
今日は 1時間33分だよと言ったら
ちょうど1時間33分でテーマまで結論まで持っていって終了する
これはできますよ 一応訓練を受けてますからね
今はもう何も全部能力が
みるみるうちに消えてるんです
もうスライド持ってきて
まあ時間かけて もう夜ね
11時半ぐらいで始めて
朝5時まで作ったんです
で 一日もうボケーとしていて
みんな起きてるとね 私の頭が機能しないんですね
みんな寝るまで待ってるんです
周りあちこちに あまりにも波動が汚れちゃって
結構みんな寝てるなっていう感じになってくると
結構頭が回転するんです
それで勢いで打ちまくっちゃうんです
だから間違いだらけで
まあ後半は間違いなかったんです
もう佐藤さん 全部直したんです
ね 前半が間違いだらけで
まあそういうことで まあ一応余計な話で終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます